pilot to Bombardier pilot the
[ __ ] Bombardier
a little smoke to set the spirits free
on the [ __ ] Lord's Day
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking about
Obama's second uncle Joey right here and
full effect [ __ ] have missed
you it's the Lord's Day today's the day
when it all goes down understand me
today's the day when the plan is written
the plot is [ __ ] done in your mind of
how you're gonna sling dick and get what
you need this week you understand me but
before anything let's park a little boat
and set the spirit solution because it's
that type of party we got the superglue
we got the [ __ ] Saturn og and we got
something without a label when you see
something without a label it's going
down you understand me what's today's
date the 26th of March it's the last we
got a month you bad [ __ ] you
gotta write your goals you got to do
your push-ups you got to pull the skin
back on your helmet and throw some hot
water on it just like that
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive I got a big day today I gotta go
to jujitsu have the little training I
had a little meet some people that do a
little riding
we got a podcast tonight I'm getting
ready for Nyack New York this weekend
Lebanese live Nyack the body starts on
Thursday night I think Saturday late
shows already sold out so we're ready to
go you take us you [ __ ] slip and you
understand me we got a great week of
podcast we got tonight we're releasing
the [ __ ] detective and tomorrow we
got the country dude and I sitting
that's that I'm saying that's a
beautiful week I've written my gulfs
I've kissed my daughter I told my wife I
love them
those are the type of clouds were
blowing this [ __ ] weekend Durst
and me I'm still giving edibles have
still been done I've given them up for
Lent I'm just living off the smoke of
debt and I'm [ __ ] loving it I'm
getting stoned again at nights I get the
[ __ ] munchies like normal people you
got to give your body a break from time
to time from anything you know I had too
much anything he's not kidding from
[ __ ] Reef for the cheeseburger you
can't eat [ __ ] every day either you
know he just can't do it
you got everything a little break let's
try this [ __ ] Saturn og I want to go
to Saturn you ever go to Saturn well
let's take a chance Columbus did oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] concoction
of debt right here you know me you bad
[ __ ] that Sunday you gotta get
your [ __ ] off tonight today is the main
[ __ ] day today's the day you write
your goals you plan your manipulation in
a week
and you [ __ ] you add fire to the
[ __ ] burning soul of that takeover
you're planning you know I'm saying you
got to take [ __ ] over from time to time
me I'm not ready to take nothing off I'm
very happy my little [ __ ] piece of
the jungle over here I'm over here just
[ __ ] hang on myself you don't see
nobody you don't see no people jumping
up and down ha ha ha I don't need nobody
I'm a lone wolf slinging dick and giving
out breath mints you understand me
look at that that's the only thing you
need the Sun in your face a little
reefer in your lungs and a big set of
[ __ ] nuts and you could take anybody
down you understand me anything any
situation whatever the [ __ ] you need 20
of life no-parole
who pooped it'll merengue shoes [ __ ] it
I like this moment with you people I
miss your last couple of days I don't
like it but we can't come on here every
day it you know it there's a word for it
but they don't really matter I don't
need to be Bob and you people every day
to your [ __ ] life you're sending your
own [ __ ] smoke signals you know
I'm saying I know you got it under
control
look at that clouds of debt
any minute now I'm gonna have 10 [ __ ]
different Indian tribes showing up here
to eat corn and [ __ ] smoke hash and
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do if the
Indian show up I don't give a [ __ ] you
know I love you [ __ ] all my life
my wife is half [ __ ] charity whatever
so I'm down I got the spirit living here
you understand me
like I said tonight 8 o'clock I want to
put the podcast together but we'll do a
little periscope so we could all get our
heads together tomorrow night we got a
great [ __ ] podcast 8 o'clock and then
I'll see you [ __ ] savages
Thursday night and I act New York
Thursday morning I'm doing Jim Norton's
and Sam Roberts Brady Oh show and that's
it that's it and that's that I'm [ __ ]
excited I'm going to chance dragon in
I'm getting an egg roll I'm sorry listen
the meal just left
I got [ __ ] an ounce of this weed that
was growing up there in the fight for
the for [ __ ] whatever triangles up
there I got it passed at me last night I
called the [ __ ] mule right away this
morning I said you're on a mission to
[ __ ] Nyack get this tonight by
Thursday he just got on the horse and
he's on his [ __ ] way so they take the
10 you know whatever you don't need to
know
I'd sit look at that nice that's how you
start the [ __ ] Lord's Day a little
smoke in the lungs you're home saying
you tell the Lord thank you for giving
me another [ __ ] day to be a [ __ ]
Savage you understand me
thank you Lord for waking me up and give
me another day to impose my will on
these [ __ ] Gentiles I'm looking
cervidil oh shut the [ __ ] up
meanwhile Uncle Joe he's got his hands
on a Mona Lisa skirt to think of the
bangle a debt that's all you need to
worry about keep them thinking about
something else we'll watch your [ __ ]
little journey while they're jumping up
and down you got your fingers in the
safe already
and there's guy that's the story of my
life baby never let them see you coming
well the [ __ ] is moving in silence you
understand me
we got to keep them guessing from all
directions Dave they're over there
thinking you're a half a Titan meanwhile
you get your dick on that wife's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you understand what I'm trying
to tell you I'm not talking about
adultery I don't believe in adultery I'm
just saying keep the eye on these
[ __ ] Gentiles half of them a week
they're looking at how the [ __ ] do you
think I made it so long for 50 years
because I'm a [ __ ] rock star no more
nobody was watching you would think of
that nobody was watching they were all
consumed in their own little [ __ ]
hate comes big dick my dick and I'm
saying like the man said King Kong ain't
got nothing on me
[ __ ] I'm mighty Joe Young by the
[ __ ] slinging dick and stepping on
Japanese people I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore uncle Joey's here [ __ ] Nyack
New York Friday night Thursday night
Saturday night
remember the professionals come on
Thursday night you letting me know
that's [ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ]
we're running with the Gambino's and
[ __ ] and we got the podcast and I hand
tomorrow that's all I got to offer you
[ __ ] but I'm awesome I could
put my hand out and say I love you
[ __ ]
you and I both know my own is on my
sleep that's how I roll
Joey what's with the [ __ ] idea beaten
you gotta smoke some reef I'm sorry I
know I gotta use the big spear for this
anyway what do you think one more for
the road how to respect the leather skin
and [ __ ] you Canada I love you
[ __ ] too I don't think I forgot
about you guys up there
I'm working on my paperwork we're gonna
do a [ __ ] Calgary tour the [ __ ]
hills of the Mounties with Charles
Bronson [ __ ] faut those Mounties that
time in that movie that tongue wanted to
do a show up there too you know me go
that's most of more this [ __ ] I always
do that but it's alright I recover Bam
Bam Bam
this [ __ ] here mmm there's what they
gave Jesus before they hit him in the
head with the hammer this is the real
deal Mongolia feel anything I don't kind
of label I don't even sell it on here
well they give you [ __ ] without a label
and the dude's got a mask on with a zip
in his mouth it's over just go home and
close the shade
alright I'm hearing sirens I'm having
Chinese people it's time to that Bob the
[ __ ] thing although Joey hasn't
tapped down years I'm sorry I judge it
too I tap out every day everybody chose
me that's my favorite move is getting
choked what do you do anyway I love you
[ __ ] have a great day I have a
great week write your goals focus don't
get [ __ ] - who gives a [ __ ] at the end
that's you and that [ __ ] casket solo
you didn't bring a band with you did you
know have a great week don't take [ __ ]
from nobody and at the end they can all
suck your dick and that's it and that's
that you know I miss Savage I got time I
don't want to be like everybody else I
want to be like uncle Joey
alright I have a great [ __ ] day with
your families you know I love you
[ __ ] Thursday Friday Saturday
night New York levity live tonight
tomorrow the podcasts of death the
church or what's happening now with my
goomah bout each to find you and that's
it and that's that I'll see you guys
later